THEY ARE 2-5-2, BUT THEY HAVE
CKEY TEAM.
WE APPROACH THE
OUT HI AGAIN.
SCORE IN THEIR FIRST ONSEASON AL
.
RIGHT
>> HE SEEMS TO MAKE SOMETHING
OUT OF NOTHING ON THOSE
BOZAK.
RECOVERED BY COLUMBUS.E IS
THAT COMMUNICATION.
>> O'REILLY BACK IN THE CAGE..
AND THEN HE JUST P P.
HE HA
HERE IN
THEN TRYING TO GET AWAY FROM  W.
IN FRONT OF THOMAS FIRTH.
BOQVIST.
VORACEK TO THE FRONTTKED BY THE.
BOZAK
HANGING IN THERE POINT-BLANK
STOPS.S. IT BACK TO WERENSKI.
HE WAITS.
PERIOD
THEY HAD A COUPLE OF ONE TIMERS
THAT HE JUST MISSED ON AND.
TRYING TO GO TO.
KURALY ON THE ODD MAN BREAK BAC.
LIPPED BACK IN BY BORTUZZO.
MIDDLE. IN THE DISPLAY AS
SKILLED.
AND NOW AHEAD, IT IS NYQUIST
WALKING IN.
A LITTLE POLA PLAY..
THE BLUES WHEN IT ANDING GOALS
GAMES BEFORE THIS, THEY HAVE TE
FROM THIS AREA.
THE BLUES DO A GOOD JOB ON THAT
GUILT AND HE JUST KIND OF SLIDE